Elena korsunova telling us about
Achilles algorithm for you thank you
thank you for introducing thank you so
originally I declared the title as
calloused algorithms but then I realized
that there will be no trumpet actually
explains the origin of rather first tell
the connection actually in particular
technology point of view and I will
present one algorithm but I think at the
end of my talk will actually realize
that this one algorithm covers at least
so this would be the outline of my talk
I briefly I give a definition of what I
sneeze but what I will be mentioning as
I will briefly introduce and the belief
problem which is I believe known for and
then I will describe what is known as a
decadal closet from them which is
probably known to people and this part
will be bit quantum but since we all
know that we are not done is any more
since last week
I would assume with people once you get
to two year go take an extra I will tell
you the to each other
but isn't the hardness of one problem we
can conclude something about so I start
from seeing the difference which is the
careless problem so what is this problem
about so I'm doing usually I'm giving
Kailas and with our passage in urology
they can leave they will be leaving an
n-dimensional space and the space let's
say in general is RS for our case of
Philbeck show this creep of independent
and tentacle distribute elements so this
is one thing you are given K wrong with
and a certain relation and the task is
to find some vectors from each of these
lists that satisfy this relation you can
ask questions for the RAM to find all
solutions most all of the so almost all
solutions or a small fraction of its
solutions in a relation you can think
about is well that's one example of the
relation would be let's take some of
this X 1 of X K and this by some bow for
instance this problem the list can will
usually be the same size and you should
think about these sizes of being
exponentially and they could be as all
identical and for the problem to make
sense we should set the least I decided
enough solutions exist enough for
solution that you want to find all then
there should be at least one if you want
oh I think one so it's exponentially in
your head that they should be
exponential in n there will be no great
there will be some explanation classical
example this problem is what's called
the cakes is when the lists are actually
binary vectors of dimension and the
relation or what you want to find is the
K vectors each one that solves this out
this problem in terms of the square root
and having this
for today I will and the end of my talk
we will develop an algorithm that is
similar but it leaves in the the lists
are not binary vectors per curiam
vectors and the relation that you want
to find is that specific think about
this we have actual lists and this
particularly captures watch now they
because every algorithm for the learning
phase errors father problem which I
probably will not have time to describe
but what I will be describing is this
particular algorithm also this
particular problem captures a what's
known as Papa Bert's algorithm for that
problem and these two problems the DCP
and in the early for the first part of
the talk is to know describe the
relation before describing the relation
I should actually define this two
problems there are two problems that are
put on my sides I live in TCP so l ee I
think most of people by now describe l
ee just the purpose is to fix
annotations
I guess it's known my notations would be
so another bleep problem is defined by
or given by three parameters is the
dimension the modulus and what's called
the noise rate and for elderly I am
asked to find a secret S which is a
dimensional Curie vector given a many
samples of the following form by giving
a random vector a from that QM and it's
in a product with my secret which is
disturbed by a small Gaussian noise
so this p1 this noise it comes from a
Gaussian distribution to the standard
deviation proportional to I that was a
standard deviation this was a gouge in
discrete Gaussian looks like in one
image and asks me to find this path this
is a purely classical problem we know
how to decrypt affirm it it's important
to know how hard this problem is
typically typical parameters for this
problem would be and choose as the if
you think about Q being polynomial in N
and squared or n cube you should think
about the number of samples being such
that s is uniquely defined and it
happens whenever Emma's so that will be
good and unlock you and the parameter
alpha which is in between 0 & 1 is one
of a poly M which is for troop
reductions that would be square root of
n over Q so it's one of a boolean you
being put on so this is a classical
problem the problem I want to relate
this n ee to is not classical but rather
quantum so here are the qubits come this
problem has the same parameters only the
same parameters also the dimension and
the modulus but instead of having a
noise rate quantity that defines the
power
it has the an integer parameter M and
what this time defines is this so let me
let me tell you what this the here
extend the dihedral cost problem is it
gives instead of giving a bunch of
classical samples it gives you a bunch
of quantum states and the states they
look as follows this is a so also this
is my top state is not normalized state
don't normalize make water stays
throughout all my talk so all the
quantization be normalized so here I'm
giving you my S which is shifted by the
by the J's and the J is for i from 0 to
1 and some random vector X for X x1 and
I'm given a mobis of this for so as it's
fixed throughout all the earth
throughout all the states Java rice for
all states from 0 to L minus 1 and X I
the arbitrary from I can think about X
on the being fun sorry are we given the
axis also know your did not know X so I
think about X as being any from random
from that key to the
now the task is to find us so what do we
know about this problem so first if I
give you enough m again as an N to
believe then it can be shown that SS
Union was high
what is more maybe a more familiar
notion of this problem would be to stay
this problem for M being one and for M
being one this is this is what is known
to people who do groups Europe Latin for
quantum algorithms is what counted the
Hebrew a constant problem so what is the
dihedral cause a problem it's
essentially it's essentially given you
instead of M minus 1 samples is just M
equals 2 so this corresponds to this
this this kind of samples and also for
the here across the problem we usually
assume that n is 1
because access so all I give you are
this classic as quantum states I'm not
giving you anything
just I just think I just expressed this
some on topics it's like like look at
this problem as when J is when M is what
when M is 2 it goes 0 X plus the second
summit 1 X plus s so just just develop
this sound for M it goes to and you'll
get that one so I'm never I'm never
giving you X in the clear
I'm always giving you access your
physician usually so like I think
morelets is this right way to think when
we want to keep s when you want to keep
the bits and the secret the same so if
you think that like if you want really
curse but this problem so here Q should
be Q to the N rather
so just a brief brief remark what is
this wisest dihedral cause a problem
interesting it emerges from the task of
finding a hidden central problem in non
in on abelian groups so the hirokazu
program as an example is one of the
example of the group which is not a
billion but it's close to being a
billion and so base so a formal
definition of the group already Hitler
group that would be the group that that
defines rotations and reflections of and
this this this group the dispute
describes we just noted rotations
reflections of an egg on it is not a
billion because a reflection and
rotations are not commutative
you just draw a triangle and you try to
rotate and and reflect it's not the same
as reflected basically this s would be a
hidden reflection
finding us a generator with a Hiddleston
alright so what do we know so why did
why are we introducing this problem one
after the other there is a good reason
for that is that so I'm just repeating
the e the definitions just immediately
comparison it was shown that by or dad
in 2002 that if you can solve the day it
will cause a problem then you can so far
W so this notation means precisely that
from a the blue samples they can produce
quantum in polynomial time
is this for Emma coaster so I will give
you I will show you similar reduction
you'll see the relation will be
developed it's a good question
you think about at the end of the
reduction will if we had ample in all of
them in and then and also there are also
restrictions on L that come not only
from M but also from your noise oh you
will see that this is actually a crucial
question because the number of the
number of TCP samples will actually
reflect the complexity well when I write
the Trekker free ya reduction think the
boots disappear I should also say that
and the bleed was not really defined
2002 but what he showed rather is the
university program can be reduced to
this but we now know that's
yeah so when you get this these
independent samples on the right should
I think of them as sort of living in you
know L times bigger you know Hilbert
space the quantum computer can act on
simultaneously or is it like a mixed
state you're giving them one by one
independent that's correct the
parameters here are not quite accurate
I'll show you get in the introduction
okay okay so you're right so for I give
at this end it Q to Q to the N squared I
think if you do what what if his his
arguments what I want to show you next
is the question whether we can have a
reverse reduction whether we could go
from whether giving an employee Oracle
you can actually solve disappea and the
answer for this question is I think no
welcome to this we cannot show this one
so as we can show a relaxed and by we we
actually mean
Vica myself dummy an and wai-chun is
that an equivalence can be shown not
between DC P and L debris but with an
extent of the CP where you have more
shifts when the M is not 2 but bigger
that's I'll show you what water gives
you fine w that comes that's precisely
the purpose it does give you reasonable
but it's I would so the notion of the
reasonable will develop in the end right
alright so going to the question of the
parameters how the parameters between n
the blue in DCP change in the reduction
I'll show you the next slide and then we
go and I was catch the reduction right
so on one hand we have and the buoy
samples and we produce Amy dissipate
some it disappear samples there are the
parameters developers follow if you
headed n-dimensional here your and
imagine as well the number or the
modulus change the number of samples
there is a interplay between the number
of samples and sanitization of n degree
and the number of the resulting samples
and the M so not here that what am I so
the young D so alpha was between zero
and one so it kind of goes brother in
the year so I'll face more than one M
and L Q to the N over Emma because I
know once I am was really kind of small
when we can say that M espalier spoil it
a man is boiling you want being on
balance sure but if you actually plug
with the parameters hand will not be
smaller noise using small noise within M
is big because alpha is the inverse of
the noise sorry it's the noise race but
the standard deviation is Q times five
so the smaller alpha is small alpha is
the bigger MS
started yeah sort of clears the way
halfway over the profit think of sake
Alfie's 1 over m vs alpha is 1 over n
squared alpha 1 over N squared gives you
small gives you small Gaussian but then
M with Big M is bigger because this is N
squared versus so M is the inverse
proportional
yeah we'll go to that doesn't know your
intuition is correct so if M is big the
problem the problem becomes simple as
soon as the approaches q1 is actually a
my small being to a constant or even if
it's put a log Q we don't know how to
solve it fast in the other direction
meaning that I want if I want to go from
in the city part l ee part the picture
is very similar even actually better we
preserve the dimension we preserve the
number of samples we preserve the
modulus and the number of shifts we have
they are inverse proportion to standard
deviation so note here as well if this
ship so that's precisely what you're
saying so if there is many shifts the
standard deviations become small so the
problem becomes easier either have fewer
ships the standard deviation is big and
here I'm I'm hiding constant factors
ignore it
I think when here there's a square root
of M needed for the number of shifts so
from two shifts sake here we have a
lower bound of M because if M was two we
could have done from dissipator
all the way but we're not there so I
should be 3 square root N and what I
want to show you is I want to show you
this this this reduction so this is what
that did for you can say B and we can
also do it
all right so here is so there will be a
couple of quantum steps before we're at
tune etcb sample what do we have so we
start with and the belief so I'm gonna
remember I want to to go from n EE
samples to BDCP samples my and the blue
samples I write them as a matrix so
there will be my am samples that
constitute matrix a column wise and the
back to be either this a a zero plus
easier and I want to actually I want to
stress it as zero and easy run my
solutions then a zero up here so what do
we do first first we prepare state again
I'm iMeet normalizations and here you
should trust me that this stage would be
easily first what you do you prepare a
random a superposition over J's within
by Gaussian also what I forgot to tell
you is that when I defined a BCP I could
allow so here you could imagine that J's
are weighted by by uniform distribution
record also weighted by Gaussian
distribution and actually one dimensions
you can
rejection of sampling and rejection
simply think that mention one yo J could
be weighted by uniform or by Gaussian in
our case will be with my gosh so the
regression there objection saintliness
will be done quality as there's a cost
recovery alright so we can prepare the
state maybe we can prepare first to
uniform superficial cover all SS this is
a classic hospital how could this
quantum step back
the result is kind of known it's easy to
do and we tender this with the with some
Gaussian with with the distribution over
all the J's weighted by Gaussian this is
also possible to do I will not describe
in half but you can do one thing to
observe is that again as in a classical
world I can truncate my gaussians by
just like put my best in P so at some
point this wait for large J's is way too
small as a Gaussian behave so I just cut
the tail of the Gaussian and I just
alright for this alright so this is
state is easy to prepare now I haven't
been used I haven't used my example yeah
that's a good time to use them what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna apply it forward
the following function that takes at the
first argument the shift J and the s
that is stored here and applies this
function that depends on a and I should
put B 0 here and they should be video so
I know these two guys these commas input
to my function from this tool from this
to our states
and I put it here I'm sure what happens
on this on this part is that I can just
I can't just compete I can just say that
this will be my new S which is will be
just a s minus G times is actually so I
can assume that I have here also zero
and I can I would need for a jewelry
registered registers but I assume if you
know how to be managed
took your bît-yakin on the left on the
right part i I can I assume there is
like zero
okay so if you just develop this if you
just look at the Sun you will see that
this some of the permutation of summons
is the same as this one now I just
combined as j0 I observe that there will
be this s plus J 0 on this part and I
just put it you could say differently I
just put s Primus as was J 0 now so
let's look what happens on this at this
part so I'm gonna write I'm gonna make a
picture of what happens on this on this
fourth qubit what happens on this first
qubit is the following so here is my
state from the previous slide and what
happens is the following so you have a
sum over all SS of the points of the
form a s minus the error vector spread
by j0 so you have a lattice point s and
the cloud of error surrounded and you
have the superposition of all assets
this is one s this is some other s and
this is overall s or was it q0 as as
fixed or is it zero it's because by your
NW sample yes this okay but the J like
you know it the J shifts this a zero in
different direction and there is like
many J's and there is like how many J's
relevant but I really want is I want to
disappear sample so I actually want one
this cloud I want either this one this
one this one or any one will be good
all right look at what happens on this
only on this qubit on the last one for
fixed s predicts s that would be s minus
sum over some G's times the fixed error
so this is my a s and there will be many
J times they're surrounded so think
about this as a discrete set so I mean
it's it's not this Christian my picture
but they're all be like this many points
on this Chris I but I'm not looking at
these coordinates
I'm working only a bit coordinates so
think about this like they live
somewhere else in some other space I'm
working currently this coordinate that's
correct so there will be some other
space that will describe it Espo's j0
but let's not look at them I'm going to
look at this once so what you guys if
there's a ball who's not like a lie yeah
yeah it's more like but I mean I mean
just randomized would be easier all
right noise - - yeah yeah that will be
like so the felony zero is small doesn't
really matter here
Oh J's also got same way did you know
that at the beginning by my construction
so it's a one dimensional house is
correct
now the the fact that is zero is small
is important for the following reason I
want to sort of focus myself and I want
to get one of this s so actually I want
to get this guy and the fact that these
guys are separated from each other is
important because what I'm gonna do next
I'm gonna actually separate my space
I'm gonna separate my spell be just
round by just dividing coordinate twice
this part by let's say
and I choose my D such that my this kind
of balls well when you discover both but
actually shifts of a s small shifts
affairs they lie in the same in the same
cube but none of the to lie in the in
the same cube an important point here
that actually I have a difference
between this distance and this distance
is described by the quality of my a
lattice and we know how to compute this
distance versus this distance which
which is actually defined by the
smallness of J and the smallness of a
zero because this radius is really it's
really the Mocs
of J times the infinite amount just some
intuition somehow we could like localize
on the same s you know but for different
J's you could somehow like subtract the
states or something
so what I really want I guess we want
the same thing but I wouldn't I'm not
sure if the phrase they kind of super
fit the way you raise it yes so what I
want is I want to really concentrate all
of this on one and the way I'm doing
that is just so just just to tell you
I'll jet algebraically what that would
correspond to so this separation would
correspond to just look at this qubit
and apply this function and the function
just takes divides by D coordinate wise
and takes the round so that's what it is
one of my open questions would be next
is how to separate the one way we could
do is that's what was her order date is
here here oh he put balls around each of
this
that would that could save a small
factory but yeah this is this is what
we're doing this is we don't know how
how to do it better than that's now you
you do it but could you go into the
detail because that is that way it's not
reversible if you do it is not
reversible so you can't do it basically
it's measuring the high order misery you
have to compute the value yes I see this
is a yes or what yeah thank you so this
is like this country okay so what you're
right so but imagine that this I'm doing
like I own a separate register and then
you need to thank you this will be a
separate register so my arrow doesn't
mean that actually transform my arrow
doesn't mean they transform this state
but rather means I add another registers
and ride the result I'm gonna do this
boxing box put it in so inside the box I
measure the box and upon measuring the
books I hope that for a fixed s for
random s like for anesthetic show define
the point and they're all the toys like
work as soon as the measurement is
concerned what I'm getting is this and
it's almost as good as this except I
need to UM compute this guy but I can so
this is Priscilla was the question do I
do i compute I cannot compute this by
applying this particular dysfunction so
if you do it's not actually very easy to
verify that if you on this register
apply this function J SNB
first input sorry this is the the first
tip of the second and the third what you
will get is actually zero so you cannot
compute that what you end up having is
is this DCP state so going back to the
question how a and s are related well s
was like they're not very much it was
random given s as well as just defines
your box
where did easier disappear is 0 I am
computed over 18 to be 0 ok yes
easy robust here if you just if you just
yeah miss your OS a as 0 so that's very
disappear do you not so using the
assumption that things are well
separated I'm using this assumption and
this assumption and realizing the fact I
have a gap between the arrow length and
the lambda one moment
and I cannot and I can not so these
basically determines the number of
samples I can get I cannot go
I cannot measure constancy because I
have only the number time I can measure
is really defined by by the difference
between the error and lambda 1 because
at some point I will get I will get like
bad birthdays
well X days it's actually I couldn't my
picture for so this couldn't be like so
you're saying it M gets too big these
things will overlap and then that's the
number of PCP samples correct I could
for instance here right so if I took J
very small so J is under my control the
number of shift second row so if I could
take J very small that would be like
even shorter and I could allow for more
sample well if I say okay I can go for
big J really then this ball would be
bigger but then it may well make
intersect with with another
so there is a really difference between
the number of measurement I can do which
is defined by the quantity how much this
is smaller than this by the number of
J's did you use the Gaussian so actually
I'm using the Gaussian just a
boundlessness value I see like so but
you could start losing any formula with
meters thick bounded uniform so you
could prepare this state with Gaussian
distribution then you you're good I mean
then you can do Cooper Burke and you get
if even if I take J being uniform let's
say yeah but I still have a mass from
zero right is zero comes from ILWU e so
e zero is not one zero is what's a
square root n so your final state is the
sum of gaussian j s plus J 0 but I'm
saying magically if you could get to the
end of this so the issue is that you can
only get a superposition of a small
number of chains exposed to all the J's
yeah I would like to have J's like up to
cube that would be that would be
fantastic
yeah but I cannot have a think I mean
either overlap so that will be good
the question is how hard it is she P is
this
question so this is my a TCP sample
again I'm I'm saying I'm I went from
gaussians to uniform it doesn't really
matter much for me for the hardness and
it depends on on em so let me tell you
why
so these things usual thinks we're doing
with the so I'm already it's like a step
zero when Cooper mercs algorithm or an
algorithm it actually solve the problem
is to do it quanta Fourier transform was
that Q to the N I want the Fourier
transform that Q to data will give us
this state this is just the inner
product overall wise of what was here
with the Y now that the X is the same
for all J's so I could just first I
measure Y I would measure Y from this
state and I would get a random white and
whatever remains for this Y
and now that because X is fixed for all
the J's I could just I could just
describe this inner product as X in a
product y plus j s in a product Y and
the inner product between x and y is the
same for all the J so it goes into the
global phase so with this state it's
actually not very hard to see that this
is our state and a classical Y then if M
was pure so if we were allowed to
actually make that many shifts as Q then
this state is nothing else but the
quantity so honest so but that means
that you can have a poly an algorithm if
we have boolean samples with with M as
large as Q we can't have that UV l om
being so widely smaller than Q and n is
small and it's still easy it's one down
algorithm and this is an interesting
algorithm because essentially what they
try out what they share would but the
underlying task of this problem is
solving sis but it wasn't for me that
statement it's actually a shortest
integer solution in a box and you need
to find all of them
now for our purposes and for purposes so
the reduction you've just seen the M was
actually small or even a constant and in
that gate and in this case where m is
small and this is the case of where we
leave we have one other algorithm and
there are two versions of it could be
back in 2005 and 2011 and the 2011 was
so I'm going to briefly describe this
algorithm I'm actually a bit confusing
what is this setup this after we've done
all this we now have this not have this
space and we have fully money on the
statement saying om or like a state
switches with the vector Y right with
random vectors Y so there's no error in
you get any improvement you get you get
boolean of them when you just invert the
matrix yy-you know classically okay so
let's go to copy work algorithm and this
will be the algorithm that because we
have a reduction from an ability to CP
this algorithm is also applicable
terribly
how does it work so our little so let's
maybe be not that ambitious and try to
find the only the first coordinate of s
but the next with the second and all the
other coordinates will be found in the
Majan that we had Y that we measured our
Y that what of the shape m and there and
all the others for Q in this case if you
take the inner product of s of your
secret with this Y what you will get
here is so the Y is QQQ so that cancels
with the Q and I think I should wrote
not I should've written not am but that
should be Q over a that's great I should
be so sorry
they should be our Q so in that case
this in a product will give you this and
this is again nothing else but the QFT
no but I mean look here you have this
there the sum of j from 0 to m and here
you have them and what you get is this
s1 with them isn't it really over q9
yeah and what you in review that was
another type of ism okay I'll give it
that I'm confused about what the Fourier
transform is over there so you get the
G's from 0 to n minus 1 and this is
nothing else but the Q if T of s 1 mod n
so you get so even if your s 1 is over
the Q and just get mobile shift you get
this notice and once applying to kill Q
of this oh this one's for you get s 1
modem
the problem is that such em such why
will appears probability 1 or Q to the N
so we it's unlikely that we'll get this
particular y although it's good but what
we try to do is we try to actually get
to this Y by combining several
this is what could be Berg's algorithm
in doing so let me just tell you what
the combination is and what the steps
are the question is m / q / M there is a
type of Q over I so the first chord is q
/ M
what why should be keep why should you
be divisible by n divisible I will be
close to the stage I mean there is no
something she'll be divisible by M this
isn't it true but I think if it's not
it's not a very big so you'll get some
so you would in the case will measure
the distance between so usually we can
assume okay what I'm kind of hiding this
is the shape of Q since we're actually
the cities were coming from lwe the cue
for iwi and q4w
and you hear I'm saying for LW have
flexibility in Q we can reduce LW with
one q 10 w was another key so for this
particular reason I'm not super
concerned about the specific shape of Q
so I'm usually like up I'm just curious
calm like you know what I want think the
one that is comfortable for me I'll go
okay so what does the so here is the
assumption the cure for the purpose of
my description I want Q being power of
two although it's not necessary really
and the idea to get this good why and
why again is not am but QL is to combine
several several states of the form that
I do so I'm gonna develop this on the
board which this is what I'm this is
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna show you how
to go from a not so good why and not so
good state to a little bit better state
and then we do and then we repeat the
steps so let's assume we had two states
which was
it's light energy one by one and we had
y1 classically and the second one why -
let me combine this just take one -
Melea time in combined this I mean take
a tensor product this is how you went
from one qubit to two
and this is omega of what o j1 plus j2
that's why - over Q J one commentator
one qubit we have to convince let me
rewrite this this son this not the sum
of the this fraction this Disraeli this
value this value would be the inner
product between s and J 1 times y 1 plus
J 2 times white
now this value actually can control I'm
gonna show you how to control this value
because I know J 1 and J 2 on the
separate position here they are making
bits and i know y 1 and y 2 plastic
these values
so I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna say I'm
gonna I'm gonna do I'm gonna find and
compile all this y1 y2 and J 1 and J 2
such that on the last coordinate I
scored this is divisible by 2 I'm
choosing to pretty much random you can
say if it's divisible by 4 by 8 whatever
number you want or by any multiple of
cubed I assume that Q is power I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna define my state I'm
gonna do the following thing
the same state say thanks here
but on this register I want to compute y
1 x j1 so why why I know classically j-1
I take from here plus y 2 times J 2
again this is non classic releases here
and I take let's say the ant coordinates
so this is a vector
what
even I don't know I'm gonna measure this
last give it
and I'm gonna get some c01 but the point
is that on this part I'm gonna get both
the g1 and all the j2 such that y 1
times J 1 plus y 2 J 2 is congruent to B
what I'm gonna have here is the
following this is so nothing changes for
the first and - one bits so let me
rewrite this I goes from 1 so all the
bits oh all the first 10 bits I keep and
the last one I would rather rewrite as
as follows so this guy so this this here
I know that these guys are all be more -
meaning that that they have the day
divisible by that - B is divisible by 2
so
but this thing as I just said is as 10
times B over Q plus something that is a
multiple of two times something that
depends on a and J or G 1 and G 2 sorry
and 2
so let me repeat once again what I want
just to say that this won't separate I
just want to get closer to my vector to
my vector Q here by sort of reducing by
sort of putting pulling out the powers
of two here and and this way I'm gonna
say the following
so this one is divisible so two it
divides Q so this one I'm gonna I've got
here which is a multiple of two some
multi popped on the plus coordinate and
this guy SN times the B which is what I
measured over Q is independent of I and
J so this goes to the so actually I've
done is I got closer to Q by a factor of
two on the last coordinates
let me ride the state
so what what what we've got here is
something is a state which is j1 j2 such
that y 1 x j1 v but so I stayed here
which is the same as in the previous
except I remove the s 1 times B ok
because it is the same for all J 1 J 2
and the BI cannot compute because I know
with that much so the the hard part of
this algorithm is not really this we
just bought some by measurement you just
got closer to Pew by a factor of two the
hard part is to actually get this j1 j2
so you cannot describe the state at the
moment you don't know which do you want
energy to live here and this is where
the K list come from and you actually do
both course so at this at this stage to
actually get to know g1 and g2 what
you're doing is you're constructing the
list and all vectors Y 1 J 1 where J 1
ranges and L 2 y 2 and J 2
and you combine them in the other list
contains those pairs of indices or it
could also store the indices but you
could also say I'm storing
but here you just say okay I'm gonna
find all this g1 and g2 that gave me
this is where you use like any under it
many good algorithms you know how from
the top two lists you can create
yourself by just y1 y2 you know j1 j2
you know or you know the ranges of this
of this of the synthesis and also you
know what the target should be the time
for that is is the time of the of the
truest algorithm to find the out to find
this so the parameters you should choose
namely this mod 2 that was pretty much
arbitrary it's kind of naturally re3
because you also want to say what want
so that this list is not anything and so
what you do next is you figured out the
synthesis and you basically construct
the state which is which becomes closer
to Q on the last coordinate by a factor
of two and then you repeat it but then
you you become closer to the last
coordinate by the factor of four by the
factor of eight until they get to you
and then you go to the second to another
coordinate or the N minus one then you
go to them and I stop and Juliet so
eventually what you end up having is is
a gay tree algorithm where this one was
your l1 l2 to get to get closer to the
third to by by the power by a factor of
two on the first on the last coordinate
then you would get when you try to
combine those so let's say we've got two
this will kill the power and i can
reduce my factor of two you'll get some
other fresh states on this case you
reduce
and so on and so forth until you reduce
up to mode and so
in classic way versus quantum so this
was all classical computations so
ultimately I think using is you're
measuring this this this baby you're
kind of measuring what's what's
happening here but it's the result of
the measuring doesn't really matter much
he only seemed like after you've
measured the state you've got that but
you don't know the state the state you
kind of creates you try okay the state
classically by figuring out so this
probabilities are usually like they
they're like one half an hour kids right
like why can you just do this whole
thing classically where I mean you get
it I mean I'm giving you a quantum data
right
like what do you want to do what do you
want to do what do you want to the
classically first part is indeed
classical this is to actually get the
correct state the state you put after
the measurement to describe the state
after you go and after the measure is
your combining sorta for trying to
create
that's good states out of the best days
and the mechanics are I guess I'm just
okay so it turns out that this strategy
the structure they describe just do the
first two one bit to bit for bitten and
so is if you develop this algorithm and
a strategy of this euro wising I beats
on the ISTEP that gives you precisely
the year what what was mentioned
previously square root to an algorithm
but in our case because there is pew to
the end but not to to the end that gives
us an algorithm which is classical time
and memory
and it requires the same number of
original songs if he actually starts so
that if you ask yourself how many
samples do I need originally actually by
following this strategy together the
target state was the target why you end
up with witness number question when you
say quantum memory is smaller you still
have to all the some persons are
quantized one by one well one by one so
I don't I never have to store at once
many samples I do need them but one by
one so I really don't have to store like
simultaneously that's correct let me do
this on the fly so once I need them I
have
this is an attack on lwe okay general if
any samples are given so I'm here I
described you like sort of an optimal
sampling
but what a strategy would change in the
case that you do not do MUC - and what
for but you do you combine many at once
and do big chunks and do like and try to
merge them on more bits at once than two
or eight and so on
this should remind you of the bTW
algorithm this is precisely what it does
it indicate in this indicates when we
have only fully and many samples we
would have to sort of kill at once
another Logan envelope you so if you put
here for the end you would get you would
get something that is exponential in m
and the co and the multiple in front
would be low Q divided in soloqueue
divided not token look L so we just saw
that the number of samples a is less
than Q so the constant is not good and
this is what I mean by inferior to
register tax however one point a one
tick good point about this algorithm is
that it makes peaky W classically
but it doesn't require many LW samples
and it doesn't require large Kyurem we
don't need money
I mean quanta memories pulley n so in
the regime or in the world where we have
we are where the quantum memory is
expensive but classical and classical
time and classical memory are not it
would be kind of the best solution
because what we know best solution up to
what we know now so what we know now is
either super exponential and polynomial
space or Cemal exponential but then the
memory is also exponential well this
strategy would allow you to do is the
strategy of dog here
I'm still single exponential maybe it
was the worst constant but memories soin
though in the world for polynomial
memory would be what won't remember it
would be expensive this is this could be
an option but that's a question particle
memory that's correct
classical saving and algorithm that
outperforms as it needs even best
quantum memory so that's that could be
the cancer but probably probably the
constant would be worse for the
constants would be worse for this
algorithm
doesn't beat a purely classical as far
as I can see from the constant although
it feels kind of like a good right um in
a sense that you need tons of samples
but I guess that's in like the wrong
regime it's like an icky see gcp yeah
what do you need tons of samples the
optimal yes and if you don't have enough
samples you have to do like more become
largely over time so this will be my
last fight it's just the take-off that
covers although it is really a quantum W
I think it does not require many samples
but it's a good thing although a bad
thing is this at the moment is not
better than what is based attacks
although probably is how good I mean I
don't know maybe there are ways to
improve this algorithm worked with the
constant and if I can improve the
costume that would be good and I live
two questions interesting or not one of
the things that the number of samples
that the number or which of this
algorithm revise some number of samples
we have and the question is whether
there is a better space separation that
the one I showed you was the was the
cubes with the boxes maybe there is a
better not necessarily efficient way to
do a separation I mean I can also pay
some time to actually do the separation
and if we actually have a none if we do
the analog at the head was the bTW for
classical algorithm for doubly that
seemed to perform better if the secret
is binary of sparse a ternary it's not
really visible here so I could not make
use of the fact that the binary s for
this algorithms
this is really like classically it seems
it seems to help quantumly it doesn't so
we're this stuff in questions I thank
you she's lunch for questions I think we
were in a 1:45